welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast
in today's episode we provide an update
about our forthcoming nutrition app
and we also cover a variety of topics
including relative energy deficiency
diet recovery training frequency
beginner gains
the constrained energy model ideal
durations for bulking and cutting phases
and much more as always thank you for
listening and we hope you enjoy
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast
this is your one and only full-time host
2011 inbf cardinal classic
novice category champion eric trexler
and today i am joined by a special
temporary guest co-host his name is greg
knuckles
greg how are you doing you know honestly
i i'm i'm a little bit heated today
i've got some [ __ ] i need to get off my
chest so okay
yeah the floor is yours so as people
know
this is the first and only fitness
podcast
and still the only strong
pro-christian family values anti-drug
fitness podcast and in that light
i've gotten a lot of questions recently
i've had a lot of people bringing this
to my attention
about an american sprinter
named shakiri richardson who recently
tested positive for marijuana and will
not be allowed
to compete at the olympics so
uh people have been asking for my take
on this uh
and i've you know read a lot of news
articles
read a lot of op-eds from people trying
to claim like
oh this is [ __ ] uh this is unfair
uh etcetera etcetera and i
yeah i want to share my perspective
and really shoot down some of those very
biased fake news perspectives
on this situation so first off
people are claiming uh the rules are bad
the rules are dumb
marijuana is not an ergogenic therefore
it shouldn't be banned
so she should be allowed to compete in
the olympics
first off i want to state that's heresy
if you believe that you're going to hell
uh as as we know uh
we are living out god's plan in this
world in this universe
therefore the anti-doping rules that
exist
are a part of god's plan and therefore
they're good and correct i think
we can all agree that that is the
christian perspective
on all rules and regulations that exist
in the world today
if god didn't want them they wouldn't
exist so
first off that's that's clearly
established now that's part of the
stronger by science canon
uh and in fact the biblical canon second
uh you know i i don't want this to be
all doom and gloom
i think that there is a positive spin we
can put on this
so shakiri richardson is only 21
she's young she has her whole life ahead
of her
uh you know she she's probably got at
least
two more solid olympiads that she could
compete at
if she's able to kick this habit and
turn her life around
get clean yeah yeah so here's here's a
bit of
maybe some scared straight tough love uh
so you know younger listeners to the
podcast
may not be aware of some of these
characters i'm about to bring up
but let me take you let me take you on a
little walk down memory lane
so one of the first olympics that i
was really really paying attention to
was the 2008
olympics and there was a swimmer there
who
who a lot of people these days haven't
heard of but he was a
pretty big deal at the time his name was
michael phelps
he actually broke the record for the
most gold medals in a single olympics
and pretty soon thereafter pictures
surfaced
of him toking the reefer at a college
party
and now no one's ever heard of him again
dropped off the face of the map
as far as i'm aware has done nothing
else with his life
uh you know the the wacky tobaccy
ruined what could have been a very
successful career
that ended up not being successful due
to his crippling
marijuana addiction and so he went from
number one in the world to just
completely just out of the field
as far as i'm aware yeah um there was
also another
promising young sprinter at those
olympics
again most most younger listeners have
probably never heard of this guy
due to the effects that marijuana
wreaked on his life
went by the name of usain bolt broke the
world record at the olympics
9.69 beat the field by a mile
pictures surfaced of him smoking
marijuana soon thereafter
and again ruined his career no one's
ever heard of him since
uh and you know this is the stronger by
science podcast we care about
bodybuilding physical culture uh
someone who i i think more people have
heard of
mostly due to his political work uh a
certain arnold schwarzenegger most
people these days know
know of him as the as the ex-governor of
california
uh which i mean you know a
pothead uh becoming governor of
california that i feel like that says a
lot about our society
uh but anyway a lot of people don't know
he actually used to be a bodybuilder
and he was a pretty good bodybuilder uh
he won mr olympia from i believe 1970 to
1975
consecutively won six straight there was
a little documentary film
made about the 1975 mr olympia
largely following arnold schwarzenegger
and some of his
main competitors arnold won that olympia
and uh within the documentary
there is video footage of him uh toking
the reefer
after that win so as we established he
was pretty good at bodybuilding he won
six straight mr olympias 1976 the next
year
he didn't win in fact he didn't even
qualify for the mr olympia
uh and i i think we all know why
so anyway uh shakira richardson she's
still young
still has a lot of life ahead of her i
assume
due to the fact that she is an elite
athlete this was probably the first time
that she'd ever smoked marijuana
so she does have time to kick the habit
turn her life around
and i hope that she is able to do that
very good uh so in other news
we got an update about the diet app uh
so did we share the name of the app yet
on the podcast i don't think we have
you want to do the big reveal
yeah let's do it all right so all right
three
two one okay
for people who don't understand sarcasm
the whole last thing was a bit
uh people getting kicked out of the
olympics for smoking weed
dumbest [ __ ] i've ever heard of uh and
i i am actually a little bit fired up
about this because
like on one hand i understand rules or
rules you have your regulations
she has to serve a 30-day ban that
wasn't going to to allow her to compete
in the individual uh 100 meter which
i still think is [ __ ] but you know
if you're a strict legalist i
i can understand that but her her 30 day
ban is up
prior to the 4 by 100 relay and they're
leaving her off of that as well
that's very [ __ ] up uh let my girl run
yeah okay so the diamond
app it's called macro factory oh
i beat you to it damn it's called macro
backward factor
we're stoked about it uh it's gonna be
awesome
uh we've got some beta testers uh picked
out
beta testing is going to start very soon
and and we're we're probably going to
end up launching the app
in september so uh we've got uh
a coming soon page on the stronger by
science website we're going to link that
in the show notes
if you want to poke around and see what
the app is all about
check out the web page i think i think
people are going to like it
they better yeah they better we've been
working very very hard
um all right greg uh how goes the road
to the stage
road to the stage is going swimmingly
uh i was 246.4 this
morning uh which uh i i'm not sure how
much that is down in scale weight from
the last like discrete day we recorded
but my trended weight is down one
1.6 pounds since we last recorded which
is right on track
uh nothing major just to report really
um within the the past
two weeks that was basically mass
writing time which
is always the most stressful time of the
month for me
and if i am going to go
massively off script with my diet that's
probably when it's going to happen
so uh that did not happen this was a
another
successful mass writing part of the
month which
you know always good good to celebrate
those little wins
and here is a not so little win i'm
officially down more than 20 pounds from
where i started
uh and so i'm i'm pretty stoked about
that
um so yeah i mean really things have
been going pretty smooth
uh there's i i haven't had any
i think like major tweaks or or
insights about the process in the past
two weeks because it has been going
uh very much according to script really
the only like fairly small change i made
recently is i've started consuming
way way more liquid i am
i am chronically dehydrated uh for
whatever reason i just don't like
drinking things i think it's
i think it's fake news um
so i realize like maybe i should mostly
because i've been playing more
basketball and when you're playing
basketball in a
north carolina summer outdoors and it's
super humid
if you're dehydrated when the game
starts uh things are going to turn
south pretty quickly so i started
thinking like uh
maybe i should hydrate better uh so i've
started basically
diluting my morning coffee a lot i used
to drink
24 ounces of hyper concentrated coffee
uh and i've started diluting that down
to like half a gallon
uh and it's still like relatively strong
so yeah half a gallon of coffee in the
morning then another
24 ounces of tea after that to to round
out my caffeine consumption for the day
uh you know sucking down a lot of liquid
in the process
so i've been a lot better hydrated and i
have found that that's
helped uh reduce hunger pains prior to
dinner
um previously i'd start getting like
pretty pretty hungry around seven right
around when
we'd be starting to cook uh but now i
find myself
not hungry prior to beginning to cook so
maybe it's helped with hunger management
a little bit but uh
over overall it's it's having me feel
pretty good
awesome that's good stuff um now of
course i'm not
on the road to the stage as i mentioned
i won the 2011
inbf cardinal classic novice division so
i think i've proved everything i need to
prove on the stage
is there competitive buddhism uh i'm
about to make it competitive
[Laughter]
find someone more buddhist than me i
dare ya
it's very in line with the teachings is
to become ultra competitive about it
um i mean i feel like it kind of is
though
like uh not like actual buddhism
but i feel like a lot of the
ethos of like silicon valley tech bros
is shifting kind of in the direction of
either stoicism or secular buddhism
yeah and i feel like people do make it
weirdly competitive like
dude i i've been meditating so much
dude i have two i've been meditating
like two hours a day it's like oh man
dude
i remember when i was meditating two
hours per day but
i mean i've recently upped it to three
and and i'm feeling
so centered yeah uh i don't know it
that whole that whole thing is weird to
me yeah um
but anyway i'm on the road to
enlightenment i meditate more than
probably anyone you've ever met
and so i mentioned that on the podcast
uh fairly recently i got a bunch of a
bunch of really good feedback from
people
people reached out who are doing a
similar thing which is cool
but i got a lot of people who ask me uh
where i'm
getting all of my buddhism content and
kind of like
whose teachings i am following and
so i wanted to share a shout out to my
boy
uh karma yeshi rab gay he is
uh a buddhist monk he's got uh
a podcast called buddhism guide that is
very cool i like it a lot and i actually
i'm not gonna get into it today but i i
i have found it to be very helpful with
my coaching i think some of the
perspectives from buddhism are very
helpful when it comes to
uh various fitness related pursuits
uh one of the big ones to me is a lot of
people pursuing fitness goals can be so
hard on themselves
and can really get into that game of
being
the comparisons uh you know well this
person has this physique and why don't i
and
i think sometimes the the game of just
always comparing and comparing and
comparing
uh combined with just being really hard
on yourself can make the fitness journey
go from something that's really
positive to something that's really
negative so uh anyway yeah i i think uh
it's it's something that's got a lot of
parallels that maybe i will
discuss later but anyway buddhism guide
really great podcast that's available on
like spotify and
probably all the other podcast platforms
and i've also been reading his books
um and so uh the book recommendations
that i have
you know greg you know me i don't read i
can read but i don't
but uh i have been reading books about
buddhism
so the first one is called the best way
to catch a snake and it's very good i
would start with that one
after that i'd read life's meandering
path
and then i would also read after that
ripples in the stream and those are all
by karma yeshi rab gay
available on amazon i don't get a
kickback which is ridiculous
i mean this is free advertising i
probably need to reach out to yeshi and
you can absolutely get a kick back we're
part of the m
the amazon affiliate program we could
drop a stronger by science
uh amazon affiliate link for his books
oh well there you go well i i mean i
think we've made a grand total of like
twenty four dollars
off because because the the only uh
amazon affiliate links
that we've sent out in any of our
materials ever
is uh in the the introductory emails to
the email course we recommend some
textbooks
and we include the amazon affiliate
links to the textbooks that we recommend
which
i feel like is the least slimy
possible affiliate marketing yeah
but anyway no one buys those [ __ ]
textbooks so we've made
basically zero dollars on the amazon
affiliate program but
we uh we technically are members oh well
there you go but anyway yeah like i said
uh
i've been getting a lot of a lot of the
uh
a lot of the content that i've been
listening to and reading
from uh karma yeshi rab gay he's super
chill
he's a buddhist monk he's currently
living out uh in india i think
but uh he he is from the uk
uh so i i think he's really he's very
skilled at kind of
you know because he's he has trained uh
you know in
the tibetan school of buddhism so he he
has you know
uh you know he's practiced a very
traditional approach to buddhism but
a lot of the content he puts out is you
know
kind of repackaged in a way that people
who aren't
uh you know very familiar with buddhism
it's very accessible
um and so he he kind of specifically
makes it for
for westerners who don't have a lot of
previous exposure to buddhism
and uh yeah i think it's really
accessible and pretty cool so
if you're interested in checking it out
i highly recommend it uh
all right greg what about uh feats of
strength who's getting strong
yeah so uh the the first feat of
strength
is a feat of mental strength
so uh a a young
chess player named api manu mishra
uh became the youngest chess grandmaster
in history
at the ripe old age of 12 years 4 months
and 25
days old breaking the record set by
sergey karjakin uh who
played in the the world chess
championships against magnus carlson a
couple years ago previously held the
record
uh but but young mishra just
absolutely crushed it by about three
months recently
uh there was an article on espn about
this
uh and there was a little a little blurb
in the article that i
i mostly wanted to talk about this just
to just to mention
uh the little blurb in this article so
you know
very impressive 12 years old already a
grandmaster in chess
that's a very very hard thing to do um
but this article is is talking about the
challenges he's faced
uh in ascending to grandmaster status
it's
at such a young age so it's talking
about him uh competing
in uh in chess tournaments when he was
really young
and so j just listen to this paragraph
uh
epimonyu was introduced to chess pieces
through engaging
through engaging stories by his father
at age two and a half learning the sport
was all right but as a young boy at
tournaments the struggle was to match
the physical stamina of players
at least five times older than he in a
winning position with a pawn up at the
new jersey
open a five and a half year old apomoniu
once found himself struggling to stay
awake at the board past midnight
quote his opponent obviously figured
there's no way a kid this young can go
till so late
so he just stalled and didn't play a
move for a whole hour
he-man said looking back epimonyu kind
of wanted the tournament to end so he
offered a draw
his opponent turned it down and was like
no way i'm winning this
which honestly that's one of the the
most
insane things i've ever read about
anything
competition related this is a grown-ass
adult
competing against i i can't even say a
kid
a child a small child five years old
can't beat him at the actual game so
he's like
i'm just gonna wait him out my adult
brain can stay awake and functioning
longer than his baby brain
like dude if you get to that point
if you're playing against you know
someone who's
that young but that obviously gifted and
has worked that hard to get that good at
a sport
you know i don't believe in letting kids
win things but at that point you're not
letting them win you're just getting
your ass
kicked by a prodigy which is i feel like
kind of uh kind of like an honor
in a way you know because if you're good
at something and a five-year-old is
beating you
that kid's gonna be really [ __ ] good
one day so if nothing else you're gonna
get a story to tell
but like dude so it's it's one thing
to lose to a five-year-old it's another
thing altogether
to use [ __ ] psychological warfare to
beat a five-year-old
at that point just hang it up go home
like whatever you're doing is not for
you
you're clearly not good enough at it and
also
you're not uh you don't have
the competitor's mindset you know like
it
it's one thing to say like i'm i'm gonna
win at all costs
when you're facing another adult
if that's a mindset you take when you're
competing against a child
uh just walk away you know
hard disagree for me
[Laughter]
walk up to my chessboard you're going to
get you're going to get 100
uh of my effort that includes
psychological warfare
no exceptions i'm just saying like oh
yeah i'm playing a five-year-old kid
how late do i think he can stay awake
probably not past 1am
all right well i'm just gonna keep an
eye on my watch
and uh j just smoke him out i'll i'll
wait it out
i will do anything it takes
this whole story it really gets under my
skin i'm still
pissed off about that show the queen's
gambit
[Laughter]
dude so it's
it's not a game like when i say on the
podcast that i
hate works of fiction and i have no
patience for them
i mean it i don't enjoy fiction
and so my girlfriend and i were watching
the queen's gambit
which was a television show a
documentary so to speak
about a young woman who was a chess
prodigy and
had a very successful career and it kind
of documented her
rise to prominence in the international
chess scene
and throughout the whole first season i
was waiting i was going to go to her
wikipedia page and learn more about you
know her life
some of the details see how well they
did documenting and retelling the story
dude i get to the end of it and realize
this was not a real person
as it was told in the story i was
furious
uh for a matter of weeks eventually i
got over it
uh but now i'm less clearly not yeah i
thought i got over it i'm
now i'm i'm really upset about it so uh
thank you for bringing that up now
how about uh how about a physical feat
of strength
yeah so uh we've got one uh chris yip
a power lifter uh competing in
in the ipf and his affiliates uh
recently pulled
350 kilograms which is 771
freedom units at a body weight of 70
kilograms or 154 pounds
so if you're hearing those numbers and
you were thinking to yourself
that sounds like it might be five times
body weight that is in fact five times
body weight
um that breaks the deadlift record
that taylor atwood very recently set in
the same weight class
and is just
a outrageous deadlift
[Music]
i mean i want to say
i want to say when i got into lifting
the
equipped untested deadlift at 165
was below this and now we got a drug
tested guy pulling
more than that a weight class down uh
so just just absolutely insane stuff
also
uh the the video of this will be linked
in the show notes
you should watch it because this is
i mean i wouldn't even say arguably it
is absolutely one of
the best like one of the most impressive
deadlifts ever performed
dude just looks [ __ ] bored um like
he he doesn't look hyped or excited to
hit it at all he's just like oh yeah
well
this was my game plan coming into the
meet glad i executed all right on to the
next one
um so you know tremendous technique
and uh you know he he seemed to approach
it
with the mindset of not oh i'm i'm about
to accomplish this
huge thing i need to get hyped for it it
seemed more like
yes i've prepared for this and i i
am going to do it uh and and boy did he
so uh congratulations to chris very nice
so uh this episode of the podcast is
gonna be pretty q a heavy but i did have
a very very
brief research review that i wanted to
mention
so one of the topics that i write about
a lot
is and speak about a lot on podcasts is
metabolic adaptation
and in this research review i want to
talk about two
uh syndromes for lack of a better term
that are very overlapping
so you know we talk about metabolic
adaptation
you also see a lot of literature about
relative energy deficiency in sport
uh relative energy deficiency in sport
is uh
focused on slightly different
ramifications of the same general
concept
in all honesty so like i said the these
two situations these two syndromes are
very overlapping because they
they often occur simultaneously uh but
basically what happens is
someone has low energy availability
and so i come from the physique athlete
world
where a lot of times you know we're
trying to get really lean for a
competition
body fat stores get lower uh you know
we're
exercising a lot caloric intake is low
so you know we have low energy
availability both in terms of short-term
storage and long-term storage
uh so the the metabolic adaptation side
of the coin
often focuses on more physique-related
dieting
and usually you're you're looking at
aspects or ramifications of that
that relate to energy expenditure so
reductions in
non-exercise activity reductions in
total energy expenditure
and dysregulation of hunger and satiety
cues you know a lot of times satiety
goes down hunger goes up
and overeating can become quite quite a
big challenge there
when you look at the literature on
relative energy deficiency in sport
it is very much sport focused you see a
lot of
applications in for example endurance
sport where people
generally maintain a relatively lean
physique not you know they're not
always you know at the type of body fat
level that would be ready for a
bodybuilding
competition or anything like that but
generally
lean individuals who are exercising a
ton
and they're not really eating enough you
know their their energy intake isn't
quite high enough
to keep them in a spot where their
energy availability is adequate for the
type of exercise
volume and intensity that they're
putting in and so of course
when you're looking at it from that
perspective you know the issue is still
low energy availability
but a lot of times the the emphasis
there is
on more sport focused outcomes so one of
the examples is
a lot of the uh a lot of the commentary
related to
relative energy deficiency in sport is
looking at bone health
a lot of times you'll see that a chronic
period of heavy training with low energy
availability
uh and you know relative energy
deficiency will result in a higher
uh prevalence of stress fracture so it's
extremely common uh endurance athletes
uh to see you know high prevalence of
lower body stress fractures because of
this combination of
high training volume insufficient
recovery and low energy availability
so you can see how these two uh you know
these two uh related syndromes kind of
overlap
and share the same uh kind of common
origin
to an extent which is there's not enough
energy
the body can sense that via inputs to
the hypothalamus
and then you know the hypothalamus
dictates a
a number of different responses you know
the hypothalamus
is really the origin point for several
different hormone cascades
so you know low energy is sensed in the
hypothalamus due to low body fat
due to insufficient energy intake
relative to
energy expenditure and so then we see
things like
reductions in thyroid hormone reductions
in
energy expenditure reductions in sex
hormones
and then you know down the line we see
obviously
side effects related to libido
reproductive function uh bone health
a whole variety of of unfavorable
outcomes that we associate
with this um this
situation of having really low energy
availability so
the reason i give that long introduction
is uh
these ramifications of low energy
availability
related to uh impaired bone health
impaired reproductive health low libido
low energy expenditure
alterations in a variety of different
hormones
uh you know impaired performance for
athletes and and for
physique athletes who are doing their
best in the in the gym to to maintain
muscle
uh we we see these unfavorable side
effects and a lot of people want to know
what do i actually do about that uh and
there was a recent review paper
by quickman and colleagues it was called
a review of non-pharmacological
strategies in the treatment of relative
energy deficiency in sport
and the reason i wanted to highlight
this paper is because
it went beyond the superficial obvious
stuff
right so if someone comes to you and
says hey i've got you know
low metabolic rate i've got you know all
these different outcomes related to
relative energy deficiency uh you know
metabolic adaptation
the whole kind of you know syndrome here
what can i do about it a lot of times
the easy answer the most superficial
thing is oh it's easy
get into a really big caloric surplus
cut your training volume a ton
and gain a whole bunch of fat like that
will
take care of it you know all right great
segment moving on
yeah but the the problem is
you're giving this advice to a person
who
got to a state of low energy
availability
for a reason it was a series of usually
intentional decisions related to diet
and exercise
that reflect their priorities in terms
of how much they want to exercise how
much they enjoy
exercise how much they value or
prioritize leanness
so it can be really hard to tell for
example an endurance athlete
who is you know just at they live to
train
it can be really hard to tell that
endurance athlete oh dude this is great
i have a solution just train less
they don't want to do that or to tell a
physique athlete who takes so much pride
in their physique specifically their
leanness
tell them oh it's perfect here's the
solution just gain like
you know 15 pounds of fat and you're
gonna feel better
that's a really hard sell and so
there are going to be situations where
that you know there are going to be
scenarios where that's just part of the
plan it has to be
right like so for me i'm i'm not going
to feel great
at five five and a half percent body fat
like in in that scenario
if you want to get back to feeling
yourself and getting rid of some of
these unfavorable
ramifications of low energy availability
fat gain
is going to be part of that that
equation but
uh and same thing goes if you have just
a completely excessive
endurance exercise volume and and you're
you're struggling with some of these
ramifications related to that
to some to some degree you're gonna have
to manage that training stress a little
more effectively but
what i really liked about this review
paper is that they talked about some of
the
other things that we can modify or focus
on
in the process of trying to reverse some
of these unfavorable ramifications
of low energy availability so first
thing uh
they kind of lay out a number of factors
that contribute
uh to these various outcomes uh that we
view as being
you know uncomfortable unfavorable etc
and so the the factors impacting the
development of the syndrome
of course there's you know insufficient
long-term energy stores so a physique
athlete like i said you get really
really shredded
you're gonna run into some of these
issues at a certain body fat it's going
to be unavoidable
uh there's also insufficient energy
status in the short term so just
being in a really prolonged caloric
deficit or a
really really extreme caloric deficit uh
you know
at some point that's going to be
contributing you know that short-term
energy
uh sensor just simply the state of being
in an energy deficit is a contributing
factor
but other things that play into it uh
psychogenic stress so just like
general day-to-day stress from life
can contribute and exacerbate
some of these issues exercise stress as
i already mentioned
absolutely excessive exercise stress
with insufficient recovery
can contribute to these issues and
exacerbate
the ramifications that are being
experienced
two other uh contributing factors that
you don't hear people talk about
too frequently one is specifically
lack of carbohydrate availability so
there is uh
to some degree you could make the
argument that even altering the
macronutrient distribution
without a big change in
total energy intake could be a positive
thing i mean of course
getting in a surplus is going to be much
more impactful than just switching some
macros around
but low carbohydrate availability can be
a contributing factor
and another contributing factor that i
find really fascinating
uh relates to within day energy
deficiencies
so there are some studies indicating
that you can exacerbate some of these
issues
by specifically having extended periods
throughout the day
where you it where you are in an energy
deficit so
uh you know two individuals who have the
same overall energy balance
if one person has distributed that
energy really effectively throughout the
day
so that there are not really prolonged
uh
fasting periods and there aren't major
energy deficits
for example around the exercise bout
there's some evidence to suggest that by
distributing your energy more
effectively throughout the day to match
up
uh with your energy expenditure that
could have
a favorable impact even if you haven't
really moved the needle
in terms of your total energy intake so
the thing i like about this review paper
is
of course like i said the biggest pieces
of the puzzle here
uh are gonna be getting to a sustainable
body fat level
and for some people that involves fat
gain and getting out of a big aggressive
energy deficit those are
of course by far the two most important
things you can do
if you're trying to reverse some of
these issues uh but beyond that there
are other modifiable things that can be
helpful so
gaining weight is going to be helpful in
getting into a caloric surplus
is going to be helpful but you can also
as part of that
strategy for recovery consider
distributing your energy pro
your energy intake more evenly
throughout the day so avoiding those
really long fasting periods
and making sure you have plenty plenty
of energy
you know in that peri workout window
surrounding
uh the the exercise window where you're
actually using
a bunch of energy you could also
consider
prioritizing carbohydrate availability
so even at a given caloric intake
trying to get extra carbs into the diet
at the expense of
other macronutrients then of course you
certainly
want to really effectively manage your
training stress so
if you're noticing you know some of
these unfavorable
effects related to low energy
availability
then of course you want to take a close
look at your training program and make
sure that it's appropriate with regards
to the frequency
intensity and volume and if you can find
a way to
rearrange the training program to do
more with less in terms of training
adaptations
that can be a really favorable thing
that contributes to recovery
and then another thing that people i
think often overlook is
better management of psychological
stressors so just
day-to-day normal life stressors that
can have
a contributing effect when it comes to
some of these unfavorable
symptoms or outcomes so like i said
i i think everybody intuitively
understands
that if you're at an unsustainably low
body fat gaining some body fat is going
to be an important part of recovery
if you're in a huge deficit getting out
of that huge deficit getting to
maintenance or
even better a surplus is going to be
part of the recovery process
but there are these other factors that
aren't talked about as frequently
that can be part of a comprehensive
solution to try to recover
from this this state of relative energy
deficiency
so um if you want to read more about
recovering from like a really intense
diet
or recovering from you know some of
these things related to relative energy
deficiency
if you go to stronger by science.com
metabolic adaptation there's a hyphen
between metabolic and adaptation i'll
link it in the show notes
i talk a little bit about recovering
specifically from you know a really
intense fat loss diet
i talk about how long it takes for
certain things to recover so
for example how long will it take for
you know thyroid hormone to get back to
normal versus testosterone versus
restoring a regular menstrual cycle you
know these things follow different time
courses
so i go into a little bit more detail
about about that stuff in the article
and
a relative relatively generalizable
time frame that you can expect in terms
of recovery of course
recovery is going to depend on the
approach you take so
you know if you take a very very
conservative approach to recovering from
a diet
and you don't really allow yourself to
regain a lot of weight and you don't
allow yourself to get into a big calorie
surplus then
you're going to delay that recovery
timeline so the the time frame i give in
the article
is obviously approximate and it's
subject
to a great deal of variability based on
how aggressive you get with
recovering from the diet but i also uh
i've got a figure in the article that
that talks about you know
if you're trying to figure out do i need
to you know go really aggressive and try
to go for a very fast recovery from this
diet or this state of low energy
availability
or should i take it slower and go a
little more conservative
i have a figure in the article that kind
of says
if these characteristics describe you
you really want to get on top of this
you might want to go a little bit more
aggressive with your calorie surplus
maybe allow yourself to regain a little
bit more weight and do it a little bit
more quickly
but in contrast you know if these
characteristics describe you better
then maybe it does make sense to take a
slower approach and a more gradual
approach to that diet recovery so
there's a lot of stuff that goes into
this but if you have an interest in
reading more about it like i said that
article goes into detail about
how to recover from a diet or how to
recover from a state
of relative energy deficiency uh and
what that recovery process
entails so props to these authors
of this review paper by queekman and
colleagues and i'll link the paper in
the show notes as well
if you want to take a look for yourself
makes sense to me
all right greg i'm looking at the
outline all i see here is frequency
update i have no idea what we're getting
into yes i've got a
got a little little research review as
well
uh pro probably won't go quite as long
as yours and then we will
get to questions i think i went the
right amount of time
yeah i mean sure uh
anyway so um there was a recent
meta-analysis
published uh by cuthbert and colleagues
titled effects of variations in
resistance training frequency on
strength development
in well-trained populations and
implications for in-season athlete
training
a systematic review and meta-analysis
and so this this paper was exactly what
it sounds like uh
it was a meta-analysis looking at the
impact of training frequency on strength
development
in trained lifters so back in 2018
i wrote an article for stronger by
science that was
uh like basically a non-peer-reviewed
meta-analysis looking at the impact of
training frequency on strength gains and
in that article i
concluded basically that there did seem
to be
a small but significant effect of
frequency on strength gains such that
higher training frequencies tended to
uh coincide with slightly larger rates
of strength gains
so uh this 2021
meta-analysis uh in fact found that
there did not seem to be
any significant impact of training
frequency on strength gains
and i think the biggest differences
between
my analysis and this one is just that
well two-fold one more research has come
out
so uh frequency has has had a bit of a
renaissance in recent years and so
uh i have not been keeping that article
up to date
there have been some additional studies
that have come out
that have you know swung the pendulum
back towards neutral
and also this meta-analysis was only
looking at studies on
trained lifters which i would have done
back in the day if there were enough
studies exclusively on train lifters to
justify you know only including those
studies but
you know there there were fewer studies
overall so i was thinking like yeah you
know
probably worth pulling in studies on
untrained lifters as well
just so we're getting a better snapshot
of the literature but there are
now sufficient studies on trained
lifters to be worth
meta-analyzing those and for i assume
virtually everyone listening to the
podcast those are the studies that are
uh the most relevant for us so anyway
um there's
i feel like there's not much setup
necessary here
they found i believe 10 studies
all on trained lifters most of these
studies
used volume equated protocols so
you know this the same total weekly set
volume in different frequency conditions
but
differing in frequency uh and they
separated out their analyses
to look at uh upper and lower body
strength gains independently
but that didn't make much of a
difference at all
uh long story short um for
for lower body strength the effect size
was 0.08
in favor of higher frequencies which is
effectively zero and for uh
upper body strength it was an effect
size of 0.06
in favor of higher frequencies which is
again basically nothing
relatively wide confidence intervals
nothing significant here
um so anyway if this
if this were a lesser podcast at this
point
we'd probably just circle jerk for about
20 minutes about how
cool and awesome it is to to update our
views when
new evidence comes out i am pretty proud
of us for that
very proud that's nerd [ __ ] that that sh
that should be expected
uh being too proud of yourself for doing
that
is uh i don't know it
it brings me physical pain every time i
see it
uh i mean i i you know adopted the
buddhist perspective of non-self so i
really don't have anything to defend
when it comes to these types of uh
arguments yeah fair
yeah uh but yeah so um you know
the the official stronger by science
party line
related to frequency is changing
it does not seem that higher frequencies
are inherently independently
on average superior for strength gains
there there are i think a couple of
caveats to throw in there
the first and most important is that
most of these studies did use
equated training volume so
they were mostly using pretty moderate
overall
weekly training volumes per exercise so
you know maybe you're dealing with
uh 10 sets of an exercise per week and
you're distributing that in two weekly
sessions or five weekly sessions
so if you're doing two weekly sessions
you're doing five sets per session
if you're doing five weekly sessions
you're doing two sets per session
uh but in neither of those circumstances
are you dealing with
ridiculously high single session
training volumes i do think that
practically
especially for more trained lifters
higher frequencies can have some
benefits especially for people who are
trying to build muscle
simply because they may allow you to
tolerate higher total training volumes
or maybe
allocate training volume per muscle
group a bit more effectively
so you know if you're doing 15
sets of quads in a week and you can
distribute that between
one session where say you're doing uh
five sets of squats five sets of leg
press five sets of lunges or something
like that
by your last set of lunges dude your
quads have tapped out
six sets ago uh and and that's probably
not going to be super
high uh high quality training you're
getting in there
um there have also been some suggestions
that the
the efficacy of per session volume
kind of hits the point of diminishing
returns around
somewhere in the neighborhood of maybe
10 sets in a training session
uh not that higher per session volumes
and that are
necessarily bad but that you know
you're not getting that much out of say
the 11th set
uh so you know in a situation like that
if
instead of doing all 15 of those sets in
one training day if you split that up to
five sets for quads across three
training days
you know with higher total volumes
maybe you would see more efficacy from
higher frequencies
uh and also like i said higher
frequencies may just
allow you to tolerate higher total
training volume so
you know 15 sets i i think that's kind
of
near the limit of what one might
reasonably be expected to do for a
single muscle group in a single training
session
but if you find that hey i'm not really
responding to that
anymore maybe i need to go up to 20
weekly sets
for a given muscle group like
at that point your single training
session is becoming kind of ridiculous
and so by
by splitting it into multiple sessions
for that muscle group
that might help you just tolerate higher
total weekly trading volume so
you know i think that uh when frequency
isn't the only variable being
manipulated
you know maybe practically there there
are some reasons you might favor higher
frequencies and to be clear
um like i said most of these most of the
studies in this meta-analysis
use like pretty moderate volumes the the
types of volumes
that are probably adequate for most
people most of the time so i'm not using
this as an argument that
most people probably need more volume
and more frequency than was included in
these studies like for the most part
like i i think eight to ten sets per
muscle group per week is is a pretty
decent starting point
and if you wanted to do all of that in a
single training session
that is probably a perfectly fine thing
to do that's
that's not ridiculous single session
training volume
uh but yeah so so i think that there
might still be some applications for
higher frequencies
uh and the second thing is you know
within a single study and even more so
in a meta-analysis
we're interested in what is it
we're interested in whether something is
producing
superior results for most people on
average
um and so
uh frequency i think is a is a variable
that is i think it's a variable that has
a higher
degree of like inter-individual
variability
in terms of what people respond well to
compared to
other variables i would i would need to
look up the citation again uh but
basically there's
um there's a type of figure that you
often see
in um within subject unilateral training
designs
where basically say you have one leg
assigned to one training protocol one
leg assigned to another training
protocol
and then you can graphically represent
uh
each individual's responses and so you
have
a line of identity where basically it's
it's the equation is x equals y so
slope of one cutting cutting through the
x y
plane diagonally and you have each
individual's results plotted
on that x y graph and if a point falls
close to the line
that tells you like hey their two legs
got
pretty similar hypertrophy results from
both of the programs and if you see
a point falling way above the line or
way below the line that says like oh
that leg got
considerably better results from program
a versus program b
or program b versus program a so so
that's
um it's a good graphical representation
and you can see
how strong uh the core the within
subject correlations are so
you know if if most of those points are
falling along that line of identity
uh and the the correlation coefficient
just for
linear regression is like 0.8.9
you can say that you know not only
are these two approaches fairly similar
in terms of average results
for most people they produce fairly
similar results as well
there was a study there there was a
within subject unilateral study
um a couple years back that had a figure
like that
and it had the the most
uh spread around the line of identity
that i've seen
in a within subject unilateral study so
suggesting that um
for some individuals lower frequencies
were
way better than higher frequencies and
for some individuals higher frequencies
were
way better than lower frequencies that's
not what you tend to see
what you tend to see is like people who
respond well to training
respond well to like the two
levels of a particular variable being
tested in a study
people who respond poorly to training
respond pretty poorly to both training
protocols and
and there's not a ton of variability
about that
that x equals y line the frequency study
i have in mind that i'll i'll try to
find it to link in the show notes but
we're
uh we're we're running pretty close to
our deadline this month so i may not
have time to find it
but it it did have the the largest
spread that i've seen
in a study like that where it seemed
like
higher frequencies way better for some
people lower frequencies
way better for other people which again
third time i've said this that is not
what you tend to see in studies like
that so so i think that
uh you know pretty much every training
variable is ripe
for individual experimentation but i
think frequency is
perhaps the number one variable where
you need to trust your own personal
experimentation
maybe over the science so if the science
is saying
higher frequencies lower frequencies
produce similar results on average
you absolutely should not interpret that
to mean
higher frequencies and lower frequencies
will produce similar results for
me that could be the case but frequency
much more than other variables
is one that you need to experiment with
and you very well
may find that for you know certain lifts
lower frequencies work way better than
higher frequencies for you and higher
frequencies work
way better than lower frequencies uh so
uh when you see when you see no mean
difference in the literature that always
means
this is something worth experiment or
not always that's too strong of a
statement
that often means this is a variable
worth experimenting with
uh and i think that applies doubly to
frequency
compared to most of the other training
variables
uh that one might discuss all right good
stuff man
um so you want to do some q and a's
yeah yeah let's do it um you
lead off with one where you think you're
going to be doing most of the talking
and i'll i'll try to find that frequency
study so
you're not waiting on the outline to to
upload this episode
cool yeah i'll do i'll do a couple um
yeah so
uh got a bunch of questions this week so
the first one
is from fit by sci and
the question is if a trainee has spent a
few years in the gym
making minimal progress you know poor
diet poor programming and so on
is there any literature to suggest that
their their window of newbie
gains isn't lost uh so basically the i
the question is can you still have like
a beginner phase where you get
really uh rapid and precipitous gains
even though you've been lifting for a
few years and i would say unequivocally
uh the answer is yes you can kind of you
know
the newbie gains are there for the
taking whenever you
uh make really substantial
qualitative improvements in your
approach to training and nutrition
so you know if you spend four years
dabbling in resistance training but
you're just not following any of the
optimal principles and you're not even
close you know you're just
really not making good use of your time
in the gym you're not
eating effectively to support training
adaptations
it's it's not like your body is going to
sense like oh
i know you're doing it wrong but you've
been in the gym for four years so you
you cannot make those beginner gains
uh you know that's certainly not the
case once you start to adopt
a better approach to training and
nutrition
you will capitalize on those beginner
gains
to whatever extent you're capable based
on
really your genetics you know so
whatever beginner gains
are there for the taking for you as an
individual
you will still experience those gains at
some point
if you go from a really low efficacy
approach to training and nutrition
and change that to a much more effective
approach to training and nutrition uh so
yeah
some people might feel that they missed
out
on that window of beginner gains
if yeah i i could definitely imagine
this scenario playing out
let's say you started out training with
a really
misinformed approach to how you should
be training how you should be eating
and instead of flipping a switch four
years later and going from
you know a very ineffective approach to
an extremely effective
approach you know you more likely will
piece it together over time
you know so over that three or four year
span of getting acquainted with training
and nutrition
you might make some big changes
incrementally over that entire span of
time
so you might feel like you never had a
huge wave where you got
you know this really rapid uh you know
expansion of your gains where you gained
a ton of muscle and a ton of strength in
a short period of time
but the reason that you might perceive
that you missed out on that window
is because you just drug that out over a
three or four year period
of making gradual improvements to your
programming rather than
a really huge change where everything
kind of changed at once
so that's one of the reasons that like i
think
training age uh you know how many years
you've been training
there are applications for it there are
times where it's useful but
sometimes i think people over interpret
their their training age
from a chronological perspective and say
like well i'm an
advanced trainee because i've been
lifting for x number of years
you know like for me for example i
started lifting when i was 12.
uh you know i was old enough to be you
know
a chess grandmaster apparently but not
old enough to know what the hell i'm
doing in the gym
and uh so yeah i mean from the age of 12
to like 16
i was in there you know breaking a sweat
doing hard
things but not eating uh in a really
effective way not training in a really
effective way so
you know i i had kind of a second wave
of beginner gains when i was probably
16 or 17 and then when i was 19
and i figured out or 18 or 19 i figured
out what food was
i started eating then i had another wave
of really
you know really precipitous gains and so
uh
you know i could have at the age of 18
said ah dude i'm super advanced
all my big gains are behind me because
i've been lifting for six years
but the reality was it wasn't six years
of high quality training
it wasn't six years of high quality
dieting i didn't hit puberty
really until a couple years into it
anyway right like
i mean you you hit like your peak muscle
growth a lot a lot of guys probably hit
that in in the 15 16 range i would think
right now when you're 12.
i mean not for you i mean maybe not for
you yeah yeah i mean
you you had a beard when you were like
eight
when i was 10. yeah but uh but yeah so
like
basically i think some people over
interpret their training age and say
well
you make all your gains in the first
three years and i'm past that but
if you make really substantial
improvements to your approach you
probably can
initiate a pretty pretty notable
improvement in your progress
even if you've been in the gym you know
for for several years
you know i i agree with everything you
just said i just wanted to
to riff on one thing for a second um
so if you're listening to this podcast
and you're
you're a young individual you know let's
say you're under about
16 or so uh i've had a fair number of
pretty young lifters message me and
uh man i i need to get on with this
story quickly because i feel like that's
very suspect set up but
no they'll be like you know i've been
lifting for a couple of years and i
really haven't been
building much muscle and and like am i
doing anything wrong
uh and i'll just ask them like
has your voice started changing yet
and if they say i mean not really i'll
be like ah
give it a couple years uh because you
know it's not that
you can't build muscle pre-puberty or
like during early puberty but
i mean if you're a late bloomer like if
you're not hitting puberty really hard
till you're about 16
yeah if you start training at 14 15 like
you'll probably build some muscle but
if you're not building much don't take
that as an indication that you just
don't respond
well to training generally like what
once
you hit puberty like a brick wall you'll
get a better idea
of your uh your propensity to build
muscle when you respond to training so
that
that is a common uh
bit of psychological stress that i've
seen from
from younger lifters who uh you know are
maybe
at an age where a lot of people will
have
hit the the peak weight velocity portion
of puberty already but they just haven't
they feel like they're responding poorly
you know
if you're if you're getting into
training at a young age wait until
you're like
18 19 to to make that mental designation
of whether
you're responding well to training or
not uh because once
you know once your voice starts
deepening and you start growing some
facial hair
if you're still not building much muscle
like yeah you might be looking at an
uphill climb
uh but if you're not to that point yet
just don't worry about it yet you'll
you'll get a better indication later on
but but there is still value in
continuing to train oh for sure for sure
you you might not have really dramatic
hypertrophy occurring
but you know the strength gains the
power gains uh you know
becoming a more proficient lifter
there's still tons of benefits there for
for young athletes who are trying to get
into lifting but might not be
you know really packing on a lot of
muscle yet yeah yeah absolutely there's
there's a lot of benefits to it just
just don't take your early hypertrophy
returns as a forecast of
later hypertrophy returns yeah that does
remind me though of my favorite genre
of uh transformation pictures yes
you'll see you'll see these people who
are like check out my transformation and
it's like
so what you you weren't muscular when
you were 11 and didn't lift
interesting and now you're 24 and you do
lift and you're big
very cool yeah or or the uh artificial
puberty
transformation pictures when it's like
yeah i started taking
enormous amounts of anabolic steroids
and i'm just gonna
not mention that and be like yeah dude i
just gained like 80 pounds of muscle it
was sweet
yeah i i gotta say one of uh
one of my favorite genres of instagram
posts both because like i kind of feel
for him but i also think it's funny
is when uh when someone is trying to get
into like the coaching and like
online influencer fitness game when
they're still like
young like they're they're still in high
school or like maybe first year of
college but
you know they're very confident they're
they're trying to put their stuff out
there make a name for themselves
and like they really did just hit
puberty last year but
like transformation photos are a thing
because they work
and so you know they don't have
a tra they don't have a transformation
photo that they can post
where the before is not pre-puberty you
know yeah
it's just like you know you just can't
use this tactic and still be honest like
this is a tool that is in other people's
toolkits
that simply should not be in your
toolkit and i i feel for you but that's
that's just the way of the world yeah
all right
i'm gonna move on to my second one here
oh i i found the study by the way oh you
did uh
yeah the it did not have the type of
figure that i had in mind uh
the the visual i had in mind of that
figure was
a version of the figure that i made in
excel based on another figure
reported in the text uh because the
figure i describe
is is the type of figure that i really
like uh but anyway so you think you did
a terrific job with that i did
it i did an amazing job um
but yeah the title of the study is
individual muscle hypertrophy and
strength responses to high versus low
resistance training frequencies
by adamus and colleagues uh and
and that will be linked in the show
notes they do have another figure in the
text
that also shows the variability uh it's
another type of figure where basically
uh what i'm i'm
getting out of the describing figures in
an audio medium game
you can check it out for yourself the
the paper will be linked in the show
notes
yeah good call all right so uh i've got
a question here
from dutch curl bro
and the question is what is your take on
short
bulking and cutting cycles like
alternating between
a three or four week bulk and then a one
to two week moderate deficit so
three or four weeks of bulking one to
two weeks of cutting
the question then says it seems like in
theory shorter cuts should reduce
metabolic adaptation
and frequent cuts should reduce the net
amount of fat that you put on
throughout your consecutive bulking
phases
so i am not a big fan of doing these
really short bulking and cutting cycles
back and forth
that's not it doesn't necessarily mean
that they can't be done effectively or
that they can't work it's just not the
approach that i like to take
um the first thing i want to mention is
i i disagree
that shortcuts would reduce metabolic
adaptations
i think probably the more notable aspect
of a diet related to metabolic
adaptation i i would think is the size
of the deficit rather than the duration
so of course if you have an enormous
deficit for a very long time
that's going to be tough um but but i
don't think i agree
that a larger shorter deficit
is going to attenuate metabolic
adaptation when compared to a
smaller deficit for a longer period of
time
so i would disagree with that particular
aspect of the question one thing i can
add to that
is i'm not sure totally about metabolic
adaptation but
as far as muscle function goes and i i
assume those two things are probably
related to some degree um
there there's been a fair amount of
research
on uh on military personnel that
looks to see the relationship between
cumulative energy deficit and changes in
muscle
function and it seems that basically
the predictive factor is cumulative
energy deficit
and and whether that's a modest deficit
over a matter of months
or a really severe deficit over a matter
of weeks
if the total cumulative deficit is
similar the
effects on muscle function are similar
and i
i sort of suspect that that's probably
a generalizable thing for a lot of the
adaptations
that the deleterious adaptations that
will occur with weight loss
yeah and i mean you know there are some
papers that come to mind like the one by
garth and colleagues where you know when
you compare
you know faster weight loss versus
slower sometimes with faster weight loss
in
the literature you do run the risk of
potentially having uh you know some
some larger reductions in lean mass some
larger reductions and various
performance outcomes so
i think it's tough to sell the idea that
a larger faster weight loss phase
is inherently more efficacious for
someone who's interested in
maintaining muscle maintaining
performance avoiding metabolic
adaptation if
you know you could do some work and
argue on behalf of the the two
uh approaches potentially being
equivalent in some circumstances
but i i don't i don't think it's easy to
make the the case that
uh you know going with a big deficit uh
is going to be inherently more
advantageous
um another thing that i kind of disagree
with
is the the concept that more frequent
cuts necessarily is going to reduce the
amount of fat
gained i mean of course cutting does
reduce body fat but
i i think a simpler approach is that you
could just do a more conservative more
prolonged bulking phase
so it's kind of like you know you only
need those frequent cuts because
you're doing these short and more rapid
bulking phases so
you're kind of solving a problem that
you have created by
by taking this approach you know the
reality is
uh a lot of natural lifters drug-free
lifters
they just don't grow muscle particularly
quickly
especially after they're outside of
their kind of their
beginner gains of their career so
you can't just high calorie your way
through that and force muscle gain
um you know it's it's not going to be an
efficient way
to gain muscle in the absence of fat and
based on
you know this individual's question
talking about doing these frequent cuts
i assume that they that they're placing
a priority
on leanness to some degree you know if
the goal is just i want to get huge at
any cost then yeah i mean high calorie
let's go for it
but the reality is the idea of doing a
really short bulking phase for a
drug-free lifter
i think a lot of times people end up
going too aggressive with it
they gain probably more fat relative to
lean mass than they intended to then
they have to do this cutting phase and
and the cycle kind of continues in that
manner personally
you know i think that when it comes to
bulking and cutting cycles
uh stability is a huge asset
you know so when i start working with a
client what i like to do is establish a
baseline get a really good understanding
of
exactly how much energy does it take for
us to maintain body weight
or to gain weight at our intended rate
of weight gain or to lose weight at our
intended rate of weight gain
but that stability day to day week to
week month to month is a huge asset
it introduces a level of predictability
to the approach
that makes the future changes to
calorie intake or macronutrient
distribution it makes them so much
easier and so much straightforward when
you have this
very clearly established trend you can
see over time
not just the rate of weight gain or
weight loss but also the
content of the weight gain of the weight
loss you know the actual composition of
the tissue
being gained or lost over time it's a
much more nuanced and more predictable
approach than just saying hey
the next three or four weeks let's just
go for it we're going to eat like crazy
we're going to spend a lot of time in
the gym and whatever happens happens you
know
obviously i'm kind of straw manning the
approach there but you get the idea i
like to keep things predictable
and take a gradual approach that matches
basically what we can realistically hope
to achieve
as a drug free lifter but also allows us
to assess that progress
over time and make adjustments as needed
i think when you have these really rapid
phase shifts that often
involve bigger surpluses
and bigger deficits on the other side i
think
you sacrifice a lot of that stability
and a lot of that
predictability uh and i think you just
end up doing a lot more oscillation than
you really need to you know i think the
potential benefits of taking these
bigger more aggressive approaches with
more
frequent phase shifting between bulking
and cutting
i i think the the cons outweigh the pros
and i much
prefer to take a slower steadier
approach
when i'm working with clients or when
i'm trying to change my own physique
can i say something uh vaguely cynical
sure
there's a part of me that wonders
whether
these types of strategies are just kind
of
a
a response from nutrition coaches that
uh want to justify their rates
basically and like we're always doing
something yeah like
we got we gotta make more frequent
changes
and we need to complicate things because
otherwise how will we justify people
paying us
well i will say that this is definitely
the type of thing that can help you
would theoretically help you really
capture a client's interest
yeah it's like we're always on this
short term mission full steam ahead
yeah i get what you're saying yeah i i
don't i don't know the degree to which
that's
uh that's purposeful or or if people are
you know find that hey my clients like
shifting phases more and more so now
let's
uh kind of back calculate a rationale to
justify this but yeah i i don't know i
doesn't sit right with me like this yeah
that that should not be that complicated
and i
i feel like ultimately you're you're
just complicating what should be a
fairly simple thing yeah um
you know i i would present the other
less cynical side of that which
is if you were a coach well-intentioned
and you noticed for a particular client
as you kind of alluded to
you know when i'm working with this
client they are so much
more locked into the process when we
have these shorter
uh shifts in phases when we do a quick
bulk and a quick cut
and so if you're like listen the net
effect of this is positive because
they're more engaged with the
programming they're enjoying it more
they're adhering better
it could be a tool that you use to to
facilitate more client buy-in
um but like like you said i'm sure
there's also
uh a sleazy way to do it where you're
like oh you're gonna discontinue
services you can't we're just about to
start the cut
yeah you know so yeah i i don't want to
ascribe ill intentions to everyone who
does that but i
think that for some individuals they
might be there
yeah yeah there's probably something to
that and one of the things i always
think about when i when i view
various strategies with regards to
nutrition and altering body composition
uh the first question that always comes
to my head is
have we have drug free
individuals basically stolen this as a
way of mimicking
less drug-free lifters you know
that's an awesome euphemism but like you
know like one of the
so one of the things that comes to mind
is like the really aggressive approaches
to shedding water weight for like a
natural bodybuilder that's about to get
on stage
yeah like you know we we've borrowed
that
the uh or like uh major carb loading
exactly
a workout exactly mimic exogenous
insulin
yeah and it's like yeah i mean yeah
people are putting down those carbs
because they're taking enormous doses of
insulin yeah and they're not interested
in immediately dying
but yeah it's the same kind of thing
where a drug-free lifter says oh yeah
all the the huge ifbb guys are doing it
so like let's go ahead and borrow that
strategy
i i wonder if you know these really
short really intense
bulks are like you know there's
certainly a more
feasible uh thing to do if you have some
pharmacological assistance
and let's say you actually could stand
to gain you know
several pounds of muscle in a very short
time frame
uh but but i think for a lot of drug
free lifters especially later in their
lifting careers that
that kind of approach is pretty off the
table man
when i learned uh that a lot of like the
traditional quote-unquote bro science
nutrition
advice uh was largely just like a result
of accommodating steroid usage
so many things made so much more sense i
think like
one of the biggest ones is you know if
you uh
if you look at like the most traditional
bodybuilding diets
uh a lot of them are gonna be like
pretty low-fat a lot of vegetables
very very quote-unquote clean um
and like the whole concept of like clean
eating and bodybuilding
i've seen several older bodybuilders
and like when you go back and look at um
like bodybuilder bodybuilder diets from
pre-steroid era that's just not what you
see at all
and i've heard from several like
older uh untested bodybuilders that like
oh yeah that shift was solely because
like
we didn't want our liver to disintegrate
and our blood lipids to be
completely [ __ ] up by the compounds we
were using and like
if our blood lipids were going to be
[ __ ] up from all of the
exogenous compounds we were using we we
wanted to eat in such a way that would
like
delay our our inevitable heart attack as
long as possible
yeah and so it's like okay okay that
that makes a lot more sense now yeah
that's a really
morbid way to look at it i don't know if
i've ever mentioned this on the podcast
but
i know i've i've told you just hanging
out that
uh during my phd i took a nutritional
biochemistry course
and uh the the way i you know really got
on the professor's good side
uh this professor had no exposure
whatsoever
to anything bodybuilding related like
just was was not on her radar
but um over the course of this
nutritional biochemistry
class we would learn about some aspect
of physiology that was interesting and
it felt like every single lecture i
could go up after class and say
do you want to hear a disaster story
about a bodybuilder trying to exploit
this with drugs
and she would at first go like okay i'll
hear it and then i think by the end of
the course she was
excited for like she would give a
lecture and then i would give the post
lecture
about how a bodybuilder you know made a
colossal mistake
trying to exploit that particular aspect
of physiology
uh with an ill-advised approach to drug
use um
but yeah it's there there were many
stories to choose from that's for sure
you want to hear something interesting
about mitochondrial uncoupling
yeah yeah the the dnp stories yeah i i
all of it um all right so i've got one
more question here i want to get to and
then i know that you've got a bunch of
questions that you put in the outline
yeah the the ones i have are are i think
pretty evenly split for the two of us
oh cool um yeah so
the last one i've got here is from lori
and uh lori asked if the only feasible
time to train
is going to be between the hours of 4 45
pm
and 7 30 pm and my regular bedtime
is around 10 p.m
are the ergogenic effects of caffeine
worth the risk of having sleep
negatively impacted
um you know so the idea being if i'm
taking my
caffeine you know trying to shoot for an
ergogenic
dose around 5 p.m
is it worth it uh if i'm gonna be going
to bed at 10 p.m
only five hours later um
my personal opinion i would skip the
caffeine uh
the half-life of caffeine and again this
is the half-life not the
you know completely eliminated entirely
from your system
time frame a lot of times you see it
estimated in studies at five
six hours sometimes as high as eight
uh so i i just don't like the idea of
ingesting really high doses of caffeine
within you know four or five hours of
trying to go to sleep i know for me
personally even though i'm a regular
caffeine i think a lot of people
convince themselves like
if i just abuse caffeine long enough and
with great enough intensity
it'll be fine you know i don't think
that's the case i'm a very
habitual caffeine user but still if i
have caffeine that late in the afternoon
or into the evening
it does disrupt my sleep and it doesn't
mean i think a lot of people think
caffeine-related sleep disruption means
you're going to be staring at your
ceiling for four hours
yeah that's not how it always manifests
and in many cases
you spend the same same amount of time
in bed you might be a little more
restless at night but
i mean it's it's really the sleep
quality for me that
seems to get impacted in a big way and
so i might still be able to get to sleep
at a reasonable time frame and maybe
even stay asleep throughout the night
as far as i can tell but man it really
does impact my sleep quality and i just
feel like crap if i habitually consume
the caffeine late
in the afternoon and evening and another
thing to keep in mind
is the ergogenic effects of caffeine
they're nice it's a thing you can use
but
they are not enormous uh ergogenic
effects you know
it's a nice supplement when it comes to
strength and power performance but man
the value of sleep
is so much more important than anything
you're gonna get from
you know 200 300 400 milligrams of
caffeine
in my opinion i agree wholeheartedly
all right let's uh let's move on to some
questions from the facebook group and
subreddit
um so let's start with this
question by connor mackin uh what does
you and eric's cardio routines typically
look like
have either of you done any sort of
marathons or races
i definitely have never done a marathon
uh
i have actually done a sprint triathlon
uh
it [ __ ] sucked because i am a very
weak swimmer
if if they put the swim portion on the
back end of the triathlon i think my
total performance
would be better but i would also have a
much higher risk of dying
uh so maybe the swim first is good but
uh yeah i
i really struggled in the pool um
and then and then the rest went fine i
mean it wasn't fast i don't remember my
time i finished
definitely like uh
in the middle but like below the middle
of the pack
kind of or probably around 30th
percentile for the race
uh but i did finish it um but yeah that
that's the only
and that was that was like 11 years ago
that's the only uh
endurance event i have ever competed in
um
yeah i don't have a structured cardio
routine
by any means i go on a lot of
pretty long walks so generally at lunch
time
i'll go for about a 30 45 minute stroll
and then oftentimes i'll go for another
30 45 minute stroll in the evening
and i'm playing a lot of basketball
pretty consistently so that's that's the
high intensity portion of my cardio
i got to tell you first time i got back
on the on the court after
um after like pandemic restrictions were
lifted
full court was not fun uh
but yeah my my lungs are are getting
back to the point where i can
you know run a game a full court and
definitely be tired by the end but can
actually play the sport the whole time
instead of uh
mostly just focusing on survival by
about the midway point of the game
uh but yeah so so long walks in
basketball that is
my cardio program yeah with cardio i
don't like to get overly
prescriptive i don't like to really
focus on the numbers too much
i like to go for walks um
and you know the more i need to burn
energy the longer they get
or if i just have a lot of stuff on my
mind and i just want to clear my mind
i'll go for a nice long walk you know
that's good uh back in the day when i
was still
a competitive wrestler and football
player i would run a lot especially for
wrestling
um in hindsight probably not the best
use of my time
in terms of training but whatever i like
to go for a long run
from time to time i would go for you
know the two mile run was my favorite
i could usually keep my average mile
time under like six minutes
uh and then i would even go for for some
longer runs i
i i would either go for like a two mile
run or like a seven or eight mile run
uh in the seven or eight mile run you
know i'd definitely get them done in
under an hour
uh you know but that's about as much
quantification as i would ever do
the big thing i'm doing right now is uh
i feel very comfortable saying that i'm
a worse swimmer than you
because i i probably would have needed a
rescue if i tried to do a
sp even a sprint triathlon i don't think
i'd finish the the swim
backstroke so i'm uh what i'm doing
right now is
trying to i i could not do
i forget how far it even is it's not
that long of us of a swim but
i i was incapable of doing you know a
standard like forward crawl
uh for the entire distance i i
backstroked it
if you're a weak swimmer you can still
you can still backstroke the swim
distance for a sprint try
100 yeah so right now i am trying to
become a proficient swimmer uh
in my free time whenever i can find some
so
so far not going well it's not pretty
but uh but yeah that that's my thing is
like with cardio i try to make it
enjoyable i just try to make it do
something that captures my interest
i i moved recently so now i live kind of
near a lake i want to get into
stand-up paddle boarding but across that
bridge
you can see the progression of my cardio
i want to learn how to swim so i don't
die
when i do my paddle boarding so there's
a reason for it
but uh but yeah that's it i've never
done any anything competitive in cardio
i i thought you were about to say you
see the progression of my cardio it's
just getting less intense over time like
yeah i used to go for 10 mile runs now i
kind of splash around in the pool
hey maybe do some paddle boarding which
as i understand it is something that a
lot of like
retired people in florida do uh
and then it's like you know what i'm
eventually just gonna be the guy at the
gym who
sits on the recumbent bike and watches
fox news while pedaling at three miles
an hour for
for like an hour and a half i mean i
probably will be that's fine
uh yeah so that's my answer okay uh
all right um m ache asks
uh got into a conversation at in another
fitness group
about poncer's constrained energy model
and its implications for
for folks trying to use exercise to
increase calorie burn
would love to hear your takes on it uh
so so first off i think
um i think it would probably be a good
use of time
for us to do a deep dive
on this topic at some point so i i have
every intention of giving a pretty
surface level answer here
um m asked about this but there were i
think like
four or five questions about uh poncer's
constrained
uh energy expenditure model between the
subreddit and facebook group so there's
there's obvious interest in this topic
uh i think largely related to the
the book that poncer put out recently
called burn
if memory serves so my my take on it
is um i haven't read the book
but i have read the the main paper
that poncer published back in 2016 on
this topic
and i so the the basics of the
constrained energy expenditure model for
for people unaware is that um
like physical movement uh
increases caloric expenditure but only
to a point
so if you go from being completely
sedentary to
moderately active your total daily
energy expenditure
will increase concomitant to
the amount of additional movement you're
doing and the additional
calories you're burning from that
movement uh but after
like a relatively modest level of
physical activity
um you you start to see a plateau where
further increases in physical activity
throughout the day
do not coincide with further increases
in total energy expenditure scale to
lean mass or total body mass
so the the possible mechanisms
potentially explaining that are that you
know
outside of exercise like your sedentary
time might just become like
way more sedentary um you know
if if you're moderately active then when
you're not
doing exercise or something you know
moderately physical
you know maybe you're still kind of up
and moving around a little bit when
you're at home and just chilling out
in the evening but if you were very
active through the day
you get home you sit on the couch you
pop a beer
and you don't move until you go to bed
you know so like
there are there are gradations of
sedentary time
um so that that's one possible
explanation another possible
explanation is potentially metabolic if
you're being way more active maybe you
just
start to to see a slight down regulation
of
uh resting metabolic rate so um
anyway the the
negative interpretation i have seen
from this model floating around online
is that uh basically
exercise is pointless for increasing
energy expenditure i i've and that's the
thing so this is a pretty nuanced idea
mostly because you're not dealing with a
perfectly linear model you're dealing
with a model that has a break point and
a lot of people have a hard time
thinking past straight lines and so so
they hear like
oh doing more and more exercise doesn't
further and further increase caloric
expenditure
therefore little shortcut i'm gonna put
in my brain
exercise does not increase total energy
expenditure
therefore like you know if you're trying
to lose weight exercise is
actually completely pointless uh and
i don't think ponzer would agree to that
that's certainly not a logical
implication
of his data um yeah i mean
like a lot of especially americans are
are very sedentary we have sedentary
jobs and if you don't
train for something compete in a sport
you're probably fairly sedentary outside
of work as well
most people listen i don't know about
most people listening to this podcast
but most americans would probably
increase their total daily energy
expenditure by
intentionally moving a bit more and you
know that doesn't have to be intense
exercise
just go for a walk spend some time in
the garden whatever
uh that will probably increase total
daily energy expenditure
if you're someone who you know
is like already pretty active and you're
like oh if i do
20 more activity will that increase my
total daily energy expenditure
eh maybe not who's to say that that is a
possible implication of the model
um another thing to note i think
that's worth pointing out is in the 2016
paper
uh there were there were some big ass
error bars
on on the actual figure presented
um and and i think that that's
pretty logical right so i i think that
um
you know if we assume that leisure time
physical activity and changes in that
um are one of the primary mechanisms by
which further
exercise might fail to increase total
daily energy expenditure
i i think i think a pretty big variable
is basically like how active your job is
so if you have a completely sedentary
job
and say like yeah i want to train for a
marathon uh
or you know you're already like pretty
active uh
but you're like okay i'm gonna start
training way way harder
maybe that won't lead to that uh that
large of an increase in energy
expenditure because you do just have the
capacity
to be so sedentary the rest of your day
whereas like you know let's say you work
construction or you work at a [ __ ]
amazon warehouse and you say like yeah
outside of the gym i'm gonna double the
amount of miles i'm putting in per week
at that point like you're spending eight
hours a day doing something
very active necessarily like to earn a
paycheck
so like that increase in exercise
energy expenditure will i think probably
increase
total daily energy expenditure so you
know i i think it's an
i think it's a nuanced topic um
i think for most people in the western
world
doing a little bit more exercise will
probably increase energy expenditure
um but i i do think it's pretty clear
that it's not
a a one-to-one relationship
for all people at all time like if you
start putting in
an extra 100 calories worth of exercise
per day
your total daily energy expenditure
depending on what the rest of your life
looks like and how active you already
are very well may not increase by 100
calories
it will probably increase to some degree
less than 100 calories but but again
that's going to depend on
on all of those other variables yeah i
mean one of the reasons that i've
neglected to
uh pick out some of the because we've
seen questions like this before that
have been submitted
uh related to this uh constraint energy
model
one of the reasons i've shied away from
selecting those questions in the past
is i don't want to
critique the model without giving it a
really thorough review
um and i just haven't gotten to that
point where i'm like all right i'm going
to go ahead and dig into this
start to finish really in depth but you
know one of the things that has kind of
uh stifled my appetite for doing that is
because
i've already looked at some of these
aspects from a very practical
perspective so like i've looked into the
research that that
raises questions that are applicable to
my coaching right so like
uh are there behavioral
adjustments that people implement
unintentionally
in response to increased exercise energy
expenditure you know so
are there behavioral modifications that
people kind of subconsciously implement
when we have them exercise more for
weight loss purposes
are there metabolic compensation
mechanisms that occur
when we tell people to to go exercise
and burn more calories
do people do some people subconsciously
replace exercise
calories with additional food when we
try to get them to exercise to lose
weight so
i've looked at some of these various
things some of them are directly related
to the energy uh constrained energy
model
some aren't you know it but it's more of
a just uh
global perspective of if we try to use
exercise
in the real world as a weight loss tool
what happens do people eat more in
response to it
do they adjust other aspects of physical
activity uh
are there metabolic consequences that
that's the part that i think fits really
well within
the this particular energy model uh
and so you know the answer is in the
real world
uh yeah this stuff happens some people
do have you know
a response where they have a lot of
compensatory eating if we try to rely
too heavily on cardio
that's an important thing for people to
understand from a practical perspective
related to constrained energy like you
like you uh already described there are
some metabolic
uh compensatory mechanisms when we try
to really ramp up exercise energy
expenditure
and and push it to really high levels so
i there is evidence of that that is very
much in line with the general premise of
this particular model
um and then there are also uh you know
just other uh whether they're conscious
or subconscious other behavioral
modifications people do so you know you
might you might have a client that you
say hey let's try to burn
these extra calories by doing this
particular amount of cardio
on top of you know a pretty high general
physical activity level
and you might notice that they're
parking a little bit closer to the store
so they don't have to walk as far in the
parking lot they might be taking the
elevator more
so in the real world there are so many
inputs some of them relate to this model
some of them don't but i think
definitely the the overarching theme is
if you think that you're gonna either
for yourself or for a client
if you think you're gonna say let's do
200 calories of cardio
in a vacuum and assume that we're going
to have 200 extra calories of a deficit
it's the research wouldn't it indicate
the deficit is probably going to be
probably going to be smaller than you
expect for any combination
of those things so uh from from a
practical perspective
uh i do think that there's definitely
merit to the constrained energy model
um but but i think there are other
factors that even go outside of that
model
uh that that would lead you to very
carefully consider
how much a particular exercise bout
is going to move the needle i i'd
absolutely
without question think that cardio
structured exercise
can be a very valuable tool as part of a
weight loss approach
um but you have to expect some of these
you have to anticipate some of these
compensatory things
and kind of bake that into the approach
no i i agree
i think we'll probably do a deep dive on
this eventually so
let's just move on cool all right uh
tyson maniac
uh in the subreddit asks uh it's often
said that one pound of fat loss
corresponds to about a 3 500
kilocalorie deficit my question is what
is the equivalent for muscle if it's not
the same
then how can you know if you are in a
caloric deficit or surplus while gaining
muscle and losing fat at the same time
in particular if muscle is say more
energy dense than fat
wouldn't that mean you could be in an
energy surplus and losing weight if on
the other hand one pound of muscle takes
about
3 500 kilocalories surplus or deficit to
gain or lose
isn't it kind of wild that it's the same
as fat that seems unexpected so
there's a lot there basically the the
question being asked is
what is the uh energetic value of a a
given unit
of muscle mass in relation to fat
uh and therefore you know would it
possibly
could you possibly uh be weight neutral
but in a caloric deficit or surplus if
you were simultaneously
gaining fat and losing muscle or vice
versa um
and yeah uh so first off i
i have the the kilogram numbers in mind
not the pound numbers
so uh sorry to american listeners
um so but they'll
i mean we're dealing with kind of
concepts here
so the the incorrect me if i'm wrong
eric but the
uh energetic value of a kilogram of
adipose tissue
on average is about or uh yeah is about
like 90 400 calories right yeah yeah so
about 9 400 for fat and for
uh for lean mass and this is kind of
all lean mass but uh muscle is is the
largest uh constituent of lean mass you
have
it's about 18 1900 calories correct
so in effect um
in effect fat is about
four and a half times more
energy dense than lean mass is
so yeah if you lose a kilo of fat and
gain a kilo of muscle simultaneously
even though you'd be weight stable you
would actually be in a calorie deficit
and vice versa if you gain a kilo of fat
while losing a kilo of muscle you would
be weight stable but actually in a
calorie surplus
uh and theoretically
you could lose or you could gain
uh four and a half kilos of muscle while
losing a kilo of fat
and therefore gain three and a half
kilos while still being
uh in energy balance uh so those are
extreme circumstances like uh
for the most part you're you're probably
not gonna be gaining three and a half
kilos of muscle
while in a deficit uh at least over like
the short to medium term
so you know the those are kind of
theoretical considerations but the
the main practical point is that yes the
uh
energy density of fat is considerably
higher than that of muscle
so if you're
if you're in like let's say you're lean
bulking
uh you're gaining very little fat and a
lot of muscle
in a calorie surplus you will need to be
in a smaller surplus
per unit of weight gain in terms of like
raw
kilocalorie numbers then you would be
then you would need to be in an energy
deficit to
lose fat at a similar rate so you know
if you wanted to lose
uh a kilogram per week and let's just
assume that's all fat
uh you would need to be in a four and a
half times larger
energy deficit than if theoretically
you were in a surplus where you were
gaining a kilo of muscle per week
um but yeah yeah the the
energy densities of those two tissues
are considerably different
uh you want to do one more question yeah
michael taylor asks there are now so
many
amateur statisticians that draw a
conclusion
that draw conclusions based on data
googled to support their views
what are the most common errors that you
see the masses make when interpreting
statistics
i i feel like this one is teed right up
for you eric
[Music]
a lot of papers in our area use analysis
of variance
and i think a lot of people
misunderstand the general nature
of interactions and you know if there's
a significant interaction
how to actually get to the bottom of it
and
ascertain what that means as it relates
to the research question so like
you know i've seen misinterpretations
where people say oh
uh you know there's you know a pre-post
design
two different groups each group
obviously measured before and after an
intervention
and they'll say yeah that you know there
was a significant interaction but
their post-test values were not
different from one another we're not
significantly different from one another
so
uh i guess we'll ignore it and you know
that really doesn't get to the root of
what the interaction is and if that was
the
only comparison you had an interest in
that then why bother incorporating the
pre-test data if all you wanted to know
was are they different at post-testing
just do a t-test
on the post-test values so i think uh
general misunderstanding of what an
interaction really represents
in an anova model is a really common one
i think because what we're looking at
there is basically is the change from
pre to post
in one group different from the change
from pre to post in the other group
that's really what the interaction is
getting at so
if you have an interaction and they're
not different at the post-test
time point they're not significantly
different then you have to dig into that
and figure out okay so
they had different changes from pre to
post what does that mean for us
as it relates to the research question
so it's a very different question uh
looking at the interaction
versus just saying were the post-test
values different for these two groups
uh i think one of the the really big
i don't know if i would call it a a
misinterpretation or just like a
just something that's become common
practice that really shouldn't be
and we've talked about it before on the
podcast but just unnecessarily
grouping stuff you know so uh
you you might want to know turning a
continuous variable into a grouping
variable
exactly yeah so you're like okay we want
to see if
your magnitude of response to training
relates to this other thing
and so like magnitude of response to
training
you could measure it as you know uh
pounds added to bench press or something
or you know
thickness added to vastus lateralis
muscle you know i mean
there are a number of continuous
measures that could be utilized there
and so option a which would be
preferable is just to leave it that way
and look at its relationship to this
other variable
but a much more common thing is to kind
of just say well let's just split it in
the middle
and if you are below the median
then you're in the low group if you're
above the median you're in the high
group
and then we'll do group based
comparisons from there but
that's that's not ideal because you
could have two two different people
that are straddling the median and their
response
is virtually identical
but they're being treated as you know
these two completely separate groups
so you just get into this weird
situation where people with
and you also just lose a shitload of
statistical power
you lose yeah you lose a lot of
information so you know i mean
it it's like uh it's like if you're
looking at the results of a race
right and there's 20 people in the race
and you separate them into the groups of
who won and who didn't you know and it's
like
okay well the person who didn't win did
they get third or did they get 19th
you lose so much information when you do
this kind of grouping
and what i was getting at is you you
could treat
the values from two people who are very
close but on opposite sides of the
median
as being different but you know you
could have a huge difference from the
lowest value in the low responder group
to the highest value in the low
responder group
there's no distinction between them you
know they're treated as equivalent
even though they're quite far apart in
many cases so
that's one of the things that that
continually gets under my skin and i
don't want to be a hypocrite like
i've done that before in research
because like it's a thing that's done
so like early on in my research career
you know people say oh that's
that's a thing people do like get it to
groups and then you can just
you know do anovas and stuff so yeah you
know don't want to be hypocritical but
like
you know we got to start teaching people
that are doing research that you know
that's
that's probably not the best way to do
it yeah no i so i
i think one of the main reasons people
do that
relates to uh some some of the biggest
issues i see
and that that is just discourse around
uh
regression and associations always
frustrates me to no end
and so i think one of the reasons that
people frequently
group continuous variables instead of
using the most logical tool at your
disposal which is just
linear regression or just some form of
regression
is it just gets beaten into your head
even before your first statistics class
like probably in
middle school or like maybe some high
school teacher exposed you to it
correlation does not imply causation and
so i think to
to i think when you're setting up
uh an experiment and you're like how am
i gonna analyze these data
just kind of implicitly in the back of
your mind you think like oh well if i
split these into two groups and run a
t-test then i can draw causal inferences
but if i just run a correlation i can't
and i mean
any researcher worth their salt if they
thought about that
maybe subconscious assumption for two
seconds they'd realize
no like that's obviously [ __ ] like
you need to uh
do like you need to do some
randomization before you can
imply causation from like a group based
analysis
and if you're just separating groups
based on response post hoc
you you can't draw causal inferences
regardless of what type of analysis you
run
but i think that that's kind of just
like a uh
not a short circuit in people's brains
but something like that
you just think like oh well it's gonna
make my strong
my results stronger and more causally
if i split it into groups and analyze
the groups versus just using regression
uh which which is not the case um but
anyway yeah so i i think that there are
a lot of
like misinterpretations and misuse of
regression and results based on
regression and correlation out there
um so on on one hand
you know in year of our lord 2021 you
still see people
trying to make causal inferences based
purely on associations you know
correlation does not necessarily imply
causation that's no bueno you can't do
that
on the flip side i also see a lot of
people
who have that in their mind correlation
does not necessarily imply causation
and they use that to essentially
disregard and discount any research that
is primarily just looking at
associations
uh and saying like oh well this doesn't
imply causation
it's not even worth the paper it's
printed on and that's very frustrating
to me because
there are a lot of research questions
that don't lend themselves to rcts
uh and we've talked about this on the
podcast before like when
when does association possibly imply
causation
there are multiple criteria that you
could look at uh
referred to as the bradford hill
criteria there have been some criticisms
of that and maybe some
additional criteria added over the years
but you know
if you're interested in when might
association imply causation
search the bradford hill criteria that's
that's a pretty decent place to start
uh but yeah like um
research findings and research paradigms
based on regression
and associations can be very strong
and very informative and at minimum
are are often the only ways that we can
investigate
certain questions because there are a
lot of research questions out there
that don't lend themselves to rcts
either for practical reasons or just for
ethical reasons like
the the go-to example is uh
like the the decades-long campaign
of big tobacco to fight the uh
the link between cigarette smoking and
lung cancer because
they'd say like you know we won't we
want solid science these researchers are
saying that there's
associations but you know correlation
does not imply causation
where are the rcts and you know in a
vacuum that sounds
you know vaguely reasonable but if you
think
that smoking cigarettes causes cancer
good luck telling and telling an irb
like an ethics board like hey we think
cigarettes cause cancer
but we don't have proof so
uh we would like to recruit a group of
five thousand subjects and uh
incentivize 2 500 of them to smoke two
packs a day for the next 20 years
and see if they get lung cancer more
than the 2500 that don't smoke
if if you think that you're gonna give
a bunch of people [ __ ] lung cancer no
ethics board is gonna sign off on that
so
that's a situation where for ethical
reasons you will never have an rct
like you'll never be able to establish
the strongest level of evidence
to uh strongly demonstrate causation so
so like you're gonna have to rely on
associations and
i think that there's um for certain
more politically charged issues i think
that uh
smearing associations and correlational
epi type research is a purposeful
strategy
some people use to to muddy the waters
when you're dealing with research topics
that
inherently don't lend themselves to rcts
and
i think that there are bad faith actors
that
head that up and i think a lot of very
well-meaning people hear these very
reasonable sounding arguments like look
we don't disbelieve the science we just
won't
we just want the good science not this
like correlation we
saw [ __ ] uh but that's it's so bad faith
and it it drives me insane uh
so yeah i i did get a little bit of a
back and forth with somebody not too
long ago where they're like
show me an rct where the researchers
pushed people's uh pushed people into
the deep
depths of a vitamin deficiency and
showed that it was deleterious
uh it was like rcts only
i want you to show me the study where
groups were randomized and then
subjected to
just absolutely disastrous vitamin
deficiencies and i was like
well you got me on that one i do not
have that yeah
i can show you rcts where they determine
the correct approach to
rectifying that deficiency which
presented with uh you know
notable clinical symptoms but yeah i
think a lot of times people lean too
much on that idea of like
it's got to be an rct or or nothing at
all
yeah and there are just some there are
just some areas of research where that's
not uh
that's not a useful approach to take
yeah so that that's kind of the more um
so that that's kind of a bummer that
that turned more serious than i meant it
to
uh a more just like straightforward less
uh uh emotionally
encumbered statistical issue that
that i often see is uh a critique
of research that i'll see like if
someone posts a figure
on social media it's like you're saying
that these two groups are different but
i see that the error bars
overlap therefore they can't possibly be
different
that's that's not how it works um i got
that argument like the other day yeah
yeah that's that's why it's top of mind
uh yeah so um
assuming that the figure is showing the
actual like root means and standard
deviations that are
being compared uh you can still have
error
standard deviation bars overlapping and
it still be a statistically significant
difference
because ultimately the difference
between groups
comes down to standard errors more than
standard deviations
you you use standard errors to construct
your confidence interval
and if you're dealing with two groups
and the confidence intervals don't
overlap or if you're dealing with
the the differences uh within a group at
different time points and and the
confidence interval for those
differences doesn't cross zero
then that's a statistically significant
difference
[Music]
and the standard errors are going to
depend largely on the sample size
so you could have massively overlapping
standard deviation bars or
even situations where like the standard
deviation bar
in one group overlaps the mean of the
other group and if you have an adequate
sample size
you can still confidently state that
those two means are different
um so yeah that's you can't just
look at the means and standard deviation
bars and if you see any sort of overlap
in those standard deviation bars use
that as a shorthand
to imply that the group means aren't
different that's
that's just not how inferential
statistics works
yeah all right greg uh to play us out
it's my understanding that you have a
media recommendation
i do i do uh so there was a film that
came out several years ago called what
we do in the shadows and it was a
delightful film
and then there was a television show
based on that film also titled
what we do in the shadows and it was a
delightful tv show
i think i think they're going to be
making more seasons i hope they do it's
great
uh and now there is another spin-off tv
show
from the what we do in the shadows tv
show called wellington paranormal
and the first two episodes are out and
it is also
absolutely delightful uh it is um
it's a show based out of new zealand so
i think i don't know if this is true
around the globe
but every american i've talked to finds
new zealand accents incredibly charming
so uh it's good vibes based on
on accents alone i think i think that's
the same thing as fargo like from
everyone who's not from the upper
midwest
you just hear those upper midwest
accents and you're like ah yeah good
vibes here
um yeah i i watched flight of the
concords and really enjoyed the uh
yeah the new zealand accent um so yeah
the fact that you have a bunch of people
speaking with really thick new zealand
accents obvious
automatically makes it uh lighthearted
fun for americans
um but it's the the whole
what we do in the shadows cinematic
universe is just
you know good light-hearted fun very
delightful
um goes down smooth
pretty funny uh so yeah if you're
if you're looking around for um
you know a low stakes low stress little
comedy show to sink your teeth into
i'd recommend uh starting with what we
do in the shadows and
at least through the first two episodes
i would also recommend following that up
with wellington paranormal all right
good stuff
so that does it for this episode uh we
are about to take a couple weeks off
from the podcast we are obviously hard
at work
getting the nutrition app finished up
and ready to go
so over the next couple weeks we're
going to focus on that
but of course we will be back probably
around mid-august with more episodes of
the podcast
in the meantime make sure you stay
stocked up on your dietary supplements
if you go over to bulksupplements.com
be sure to use the checkout code sbs pod
and it'll save you five percent
on your order as always thank you for
listening and we'll be back soon
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter
to get concise breakdowns of relevant
research as well as 28 free training
programs
for all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam
just as much as you do so we'll only
email you when we have something really
interesting to share with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button
at the top if you want to join in on the
stronger by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified health
care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode
of the stronger by science podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you